another bus with migrants on board
arrived in washington d.c this morning
as texas governor greg abbott continues
to send thousands of migrants to cities
run by democrats abbott and new york
city mayor eric adams as a result of
this are now in a bitter feud with the
texas governor saying the policy is in
response to president biden's
immigration policies and adam's
countering that texas is using innocent
people as political pawns in his view
nancy chen has more
as three buses arrived in new york city
from texas wednesday they carried nearly
a hundred people in search of a home
including this 38-year-old man from
venezuela
saying i was very tired and stressed
during the trip volunteers like john
torres and his wife telmo rivera were
there to greet them we're going to give
them money so they can at least eat
breakfast and
or lunch or buy formula for the babies
or pampers
something that will at least help
governor greg abbott's office says texas
has sent more than 6 600 asylum seekers
who've already been processed and
released by the department of homeland
security to washington d.c in new york
since april he says to alleviate stress
on border cities they cannot handle the
overwhelming number of illegal
immigrants coming across the border
one way of assisting them is by removing
those illegal immigrants to washington
dc or new york but new york mayor eric
adams calls it horrific as the city
opens 11 additional shelters to meet the
demand if his ancestors were treated the
way he's treated these asylum seekers
and migrants then he would not be where
he is right now
asylum seekers like joanna who fled
venezuela with her children earlier this
year they spent many long hours on a bus
from texas to d.c last month
juana says the sacrifice was worth it
what governor abbott is doing is using
our clients as pawns catherine cliff a
staff attorney at the legal aid society
says abbott's plan is creating a dire
situation i think it's traumatizing you
know if it's one thing for clients to
come to new york city because that's
where they want to be but to send
families and individuals who do not want
to be here and then they have to figure
out how to get where they really want to
go is dehumanizing for cbs morning's
nancy chen new york